did bill skarsgård creep you out does he
creep you out on the set when he's
playing penny wise I'm really tough so I
was unprepared I I cuz I thought I could
have kind of handle anything and then we
were at the table read and he was
sitting where you are and actually this
was the same configuration and we're
reading and then all of a sudden
everyone's normal everyone's acting
normal and not weird and then all of a
sudden Bill starts saying his character
and he just turned to me and like
screamed in my face boo you know like
that weird voice again yeah and I yelled
like I was six years old in front of
everyone in front of all the executives
at Warner Brothers and it was so
embarrassed yeah he's still we shall
profit from this penny wise still has it
yes James where were you you you creeped
out by by his performance or the song
and did he enter your dreams after
making me
I'm just generally creeped out by clones
but I I read the book when I was a kid
and it didn't scare me I just seemed to
remember but as an adult reading it
again
I definitely had penny wise and my
thoughts and I definitely at Bill and my
thoughts name but I remember one dream
that I had where I was lying on my side
in bed and he was behind me stroking my
back oh and he was saying hey baby wake
up I guess it was like like
is it possible that that was Bill stars
baby that he's done that to me and yeah
how'd you get into my summer homes have
to pretend to be asleep